while some breaking news now and at
least six people have been killed in a
shooting at a hospital in the Czech
Republic it happened in the eastern city
of Ostrava p-police are currently
searching for the attacker well right
now we can speak to Teodor ma Janovich
who's a journalist I believe it Czech
television he joins us now on the phone
from Prague Tyrael tell us what we about
what we know at this stage I believe
police have actually put out some kind
of a call and identification about the
attacker what more do we know mmm hello
hello from Prague so look the country is
in the shock this is a very rare
incident this kind of shootings happen
very rarely in this country what we do
know is that the gunman entered the
hospital in Ostrava which is a city in
the Northeast close to the border with
Poland and opened fire on ER people in
the waiting room and then after this
shooting the gunman left and is still on
the run so there's a huge police
operation right now in the city and they
are looking for for a guy in a red
jacket and so this is all we know we
don't know about his motivation we don't
know what what why did this why did he
do this and there's a some confusion
about the number of casualties according
to some police sources four people have
died according to other police sources
six people have died tittle talk us
through how this unfolded actually at
the hospital there have also been
different reports about which part of
the hospital what do we know for sure we
know for sure that this this was not an
employee this was a guy who entered the
hospital with the gun in with a
concealed gun apparently and then he he
just entered one of the waiting rooms
inside of the hospitals and killed
people from the very short distance he
actually pointed the gun towards their
head or neck and shooted them one after
another and then he left that's what we
know so far
and as
told you we don't know about the
motivation but we according to the
police sources it might look that this
was a local guy this was not like
international terrorist so many anything
like in that sense Tia Dalma Janovich
there a journalist at Czech TV speaking
to us on the phone from Prague we'll be
bringing you more on that story as we
get it